advocates of immigration reform are
hoping for a yes vote on Sunday they
want limits put on the number of EU
citizens allowed into Switzerland each
year the right-wing Swiss people's party
is behind the new plan they insist a cap
on immigration is absolutely critical
year the Mun helpless everyone has
completely underestimated immigration
the figures are so surprising they're
much higher than in every other country
in the world immigration is becoming
overwhelming in Switzerland or via for
these rides a lubricant last year about
60,000 EU citizens moved to Switzerland
this figure represents a workforce
that's badly needed in many sectors such
as in the health system let's see how
that undoubtedly also has something to
do with the fact that changes in the
population structure and in our
demographics don't allow us to train
enough people in my hopes or feel
annoyed our speed many experts fear that
if the majority of Swiss back a cap on
immigration the country will suffer
economically I'll ask mystified firstly
because Swiss companies would have
limited access to the EU market and
secondly because companies would have to
make more effort to find the workers
they need our bites crafted significant
idea ultimately it's the Swiss
themselves who will decide at the ballot
box on Sunday what their relationship
with the EU will look like in the future